Compare the expressions on both
sides of the question marks.
So on the left-hand side of the
question mark, I have 7,907.
So, it's 7,000 plus
900 plus 7, which
is going to be the
same thing as 7,907.
Now let's compare
that to what we
have on the right-hand
side of the question mark.
On the right-hand side, we have
7,000 plus 970, which is 7,970.
Or if we wanted
to expand it out,
we could write that as
7,000 plus 900 plus 70,
and then we have 0 ones.
So if we compare place
value by place value,
we have 7,000 in either case.
So the thousands
place is the same.
We have the same
number of hundreds.
We have 9 hundreds.
But here we have no
tens, and we have a 7.
And here we have no
ones, and we have 70.
And clearly, 70
is greater than 7.
So the number on
the right is greater
than the number on the left,
or the number on the left
is less than the
number on the right.
I always remember
the less than symbol
because it points to the
smaller number, or either
of these symbols point
to the smaller number.
So this right over here
would mean greater than.
You have the larger
number on the left.
This is less than.
You have the smaller
number on the left.
So we would go with less than.
This is less than that.